[Music]
from space it would look like earth had
a giant pimple
smack dab in the middle of brazil
back on the ground you'd be astonished
by the enormity of olympus mons the
tallest mountain in our solar system
which also happens to be
a massive volcano
if this martian colossus was located in
south america
how catastrophic would its eruption be
why would you never experience an
earthquake
and why would countries start wars over
this epic mountain
this is what if and here's what would
happen if olympus mons was located in
south america
no other mountain in our solar system
rises above the 25 kilometer height of
olympus mons
to put that into perspective olympus is
over two and a half times taller than
mount everest
and this flat top giant isn't only tall
it's also really wide
on earth the base of olympus mons would
cover ecuador entirely
but here's a twist for a volcano this
large to form on our planet
earth would need some big changes under
its crest
deep in our planet's mantle there are
areas that are unusually hot
these are known as hot spots
from these hot spots large amounts of
magma rise breaking through the earth's
crust
and that's how volcanoes are formed
but because earth's crust is made up of
moving tectonic plates a volcano will
eventually move away from the hot spots
that formed it and as such stop growing
that's why a volcano as large as olympus
mons could never be formed on the earth
we know today
the reason why mars is able to house
more massive volcanoes is that unlike
our planet it doesn't have these moving
tectonic plates
this means that on mars volcanoes remain
on top of their hot spot and continue
growing
now take away the earth's tectonic
plates and we could grow our own olympus
mons
and on the bright side no tectonic
plates would mean no earthquakes
ever
and we'd likely still live on the first
super continent rodinia
that's because the plates wouldn't move
and break the land into separate
continents like we have now
now on the not so bright side this super
volcano could cause some damage
how long would we have before it rained
fire and ash all over humanity
well not all volcanoes are the same and
we might have a chance to survive
olympus mons erupting
so you shouldn't judge a book by its
cover
or a mountain by its size
olympus mons is a shield volcano that
means it doesn't chaotically spew melted
rock out causing planetary destruction
in the process
when volcanoes like olympus mons erupt
it usually isn't a violent explosion
instead they tend to produce a steady
and long-lasting flow of lava
and that's good news
lava flows are easy to spot predict and
avoid
so there wouldn't be a catastrophic
apocalypse when olympus mons went off
it might not even have a major impact
when it comes to climate change
that's because shield volcanoes don't
release much gas or debris
lucky you
and just to sweeten the deal olympus
mons wouldn't erupt today
the last time would have been between 20
and 200 million years ago
the dinosaurs wouldn't have fared so
well though
many would have died due to constant
volcanic eruptions
but wait there's more
living around olympus mons could bring
you lots of cash
that's because the ground around this
grand volcano's base would be rich with
minerals from its basaltic magma
including magnesium
this would seriously improve the quality
of agricultural soil
time to get into the agricultural
business
and that's not all even if the volcano
is active it creates geothermal energy
just like some cities in the united
states currently generate electricity
from smaller volcanoes
and you can bet it would be a year-round
tourist attraction
but now hold off on your victory lap an
earthly olympus mons would bring some
problems with it
man-made problems to be precise
volcanoes produce natural resources like
diamonds gold and nickel so naturally
south american countries that share
portions of olympus mons would see a
steep increase in wealth
and like history has shown
violent and destructive conflicts over
these resources would be inevitable just
like diamonds fueled civil wars in
africa which lasted over a decade and
left thousands dead
south america's long history of social
and political unrest would be aggravated
by olympus mons's treasures around it
blood could flow much more commonly than
lava
so
keep olympus mons where it belongs on
mars
if anything you need to watch out for
the super volcano at yellowstone park
that baby sure is active and its
eruption would even make breathing a
hazard
but
that's a story
for another what if
[Music]